Oh
Oh
you
hello I'm dr. leanna's Annette of the
University of Western Ontario in london
ontario canada this is the traditional
view we have a predator-prey
interactions predators killing prey in
this case predators eating the eggs and
nestlings of songbirds predators of
course also scare prey and our research
shows that fear itself is powerful
enough to affect the population dynamics
of wildlife specifically we found that
fear alone caused a forty percent
reduction in the number of offspring
songbirds produced per year we studied
the admittedly drab but spectacular
sounding song sparrow on the glorious
Gulf Islands beautiful British Columbia
Canada to isolate the effects of fear
itself we first had to eliminate direct
predation which we did by protecting
every nest in the experiment against
predators we protect it against raccoons
and other mammals by surrounding every
nest with electric fencing and we
covered every nest with same netting
which allowed the sparrows to get to
their nests but prevented predatory
Birds like this crow from doing so we
were able to verify that we had
successfully eliminated direct predation
by placing miniature cameras on every
nest that permitted us to record
everything that happened using several
custom-built continuous video
surveillance systems to manipulate fear
we hung speakers from trees every point
four hectares over a sixteen hectare
area some of which broadcast predator
calls and sounds aah aah like this raven
while speakers at other locations
broadcast non predator calls and sounds
all of this chaos broadcast in a few
minutes 24 hours a day over the entire
130 day breeding season females exposed
to predator playbacks throughout the
season built their nests in denser
thorny or vegetation like this female
who is nested in a rose bush to better
protect herself they were also more
skittish like this female who is flushed
from the nest in the middle of the night
exposing her eggs to the cold and so
reducing the like
that they will hatch predator playback
females also spent less time incubating
their eggs and fed their nestlings less
often which we were able to quantify
using our camera systems as you can see
here all of these effects on behavior
translated into effects on the number of
offspring produced because predator
playback females lead fewer eggs more
their eggs failed to hatch as we can see
here where there are two unhatched eggs
in the nest together with two nestlings
and a greater proportion of their
nestlings starve to death which is what
is happening here the nestling on the
left has already died and the nestling
in the foreground is slowly dying as
well the cumulative result being that
predator playback females produced forty
percent fewer offspring over the season
meaning that forty percent fewer young
successfully fledged from the nest as
these young are doing here our
experimental results corroborate recent
correlative studies that suggest fear of
wolves affects reproduction in elk fear
of links affects reproduction in
snowshoe hares and even the fear of
sharks affects their prey coming back to
songbirds our results suggest that
introduced predators like this feral cat
are causing population declines not just
because they're killing birds but
because they are instilling fear and
terror in them in much the same way that
rats instill fear and terror in most of
us